what's up guys we're pond finiti since
you guys loved the previous item battle
we're doing a part two we have 21 items
and we'll be playing one point with each
of them and since Christmas is right
around the corner that will be the theme
for today a good luck ammo
good luck first item normal racket
whoa.good
okay next one if chocolate bar milk
chocolates with salty toffee crunch
[Music]
always trust the toffee okay the sledge
oh yeah now this is one I think that's
the wrong tack no no this is good that's
how it goes when you try to cheat okay
sledge against stitch
this is just the beginning okay next up
the club I think I know how to play with
this one is this server loud
[Applause]
[Music]
oh come on okay this one won't be as
easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes like I look back I think the ski
should be quite easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no it's so close there's actually
okay feeling in this game surprising
yeah Christmas card develop the best
serve for a downhill skier the serve was
good but I wasn't ready for the next one
I was surprised by the sir it was
actually good
[Music]
Christmas card
Oh No Oh No
counter-attack ah good card okay helmet
against helmet
maybe I try em else tactic
[Music]
[Music]
Christmas present I wonder what's in
here
[Music]
yeah okay so I get to open my present
first this is really exciting oh I think
I know what this is oh yes suppose
affinity hoodie
I wish I get upon finiti hoodie I wonder
what what's inside me it's present now
the question is how should I play with
this oh no no no no there isn't like an
even surface here so it's a bit
difficult
yeah it's so random
now I get to open my present I have a
small feeling that it's a pong Trinity
hoodie I'm not sure
oh there is pong Finity hoodie ice
scraper and brush what I want to save
yes yes
okay brush against brush
[Music]
yeah no this one's a Christmas a wooden
Christmas sock it's gonna be hard
ah okay so this is apparently my
Christmas decoration Christmas tree you
know of they say when it comes to trees
and socks socks always win I don't know
what finished saying yes oh yes whoop
good smash whatever I think the balls
over there really yes yes a very fruity
wine quite bouncy
I love the spin
[Music]
okay I guess I want Christmas light
[Applause]
shut up
oh sure that was pretty cool oh I'll be
tempted to eat this one
now looks so scared Oh
did something come yeah okay this is a
bit dangerous I'll ditch the whipping
strategy next one but I won the fight it
was my plan all along that was a good
strategy yeah I have to finish my
previous racket just a minute
aha you're you're having that's threaded
okay
[Music]
time for the tiny Christmas lady
[Music]
yes so it seems that my Christmas
decoration is a snowman and Christmas
lady
yeah it's perfect yes
okay the Christmas decoration or the
Christmas ball coming distractions
candle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've done weird it back up I don't know
I should switch to the candle this one
was good the final object the knife no I
guess that means I won the point
okay so Amy's racket broke such an
unexpected ending well that was a good
idea with the spinning sir you're such a
nice idea
bye good match if you enjoyed this game
make sure to subscribe here and watch
the previous episodes there Merry
Christmas
[Music]